what are the projects you have coming up
i see you're sponsored by uh carritos
you're in commercials now um yeah for
sweater x
is like a a mexican brand pedialyte
but it's for for mexico and um we're
just investing investing
the money um buying lots right now we're
on the verge of uh finishing the 26
houses uh
that means you don't pay real estate
because it's not making any more of that
real estate yeah as much as you can
so you're in real estate well thanks to
my dad
and the people around me they're helping
me out a lot and
you know because boxing's not forever
you know you have to pressure your money
and
some guy told me his name is mr monday
and he told me
rule number one is don't lose what you
got and
no just to be smart and and the first
times i was buying dumb stuff
i feel like anybody would but you know
we i have five kids so i gotta look for
their future
and my future as well but as long as i
keep listening to to the older guys that
know
how to invest the money and know how to
manage the money then i'm
sure we're gonna be good you know when i
when i didn't have it
i wanted it so bad now that i have it i
don't want it anymore
that's how i feel with all the cars that
i have the toys and stuff
yeah you can't drive them because
there's no gas in them because
there's too many cars being driven you
know
tell me about you tell me about your
kids man five kids bro
god leave it yeah i was gonna shoot
blanks dude
[Laughter]
no i was actually gonna bring my son he
was with me everywhere he goes with me
everywhere
he was there at the fights as well he's
a
character kid man he's crazy not shy of
anything
he'll go up to like hey what's up like
what is that or
he's he's really he's amazing you know
i'm nobody knows just my opinion but i
don't even think what's the purpose of
living he's not gonna have children
right yeah and that's your time machine
your kids are your time machine you have
kids no
i'm actually well i'm about to have a a
baby girl but i'm 34
so i'm saying mexican bar you need to
catch up
i shoot blanks dude i don't know did i i
don't got that
i don't got daddy
a lot of that a lot of your motivation
that comes from your family yeah of
course my kids my
my dad's always been there even me and
him we love each other we hate each
other but he
at the end of the day he's always right
there behind me telling me
what i should be doing you know even if
i don't want to hear he still tells me
if i'm [ __ ] up or if i'm not doing
this right and
it's good to have people like that you
[Music]
know